bastien bulli journalistes web pour rt
france bonjour alors la france doit-elle
comme héros et napoléon c'est notre
sujet ce matin le 5 mai sera la date
anniversaire des 200 ans de la mort de
napoléon la france va t-elle
officiellement donc commémorer l'ancien
empereur des français
cette question divise
nous avons contacté les matignon qui
nous a précisé qu'à ce stade je cite il
n'y avait pas de séquence particulière
de programme et que l'agenda du premier
ministre dépend des également du
contexte sanitaire l'elysée pour sa part
nous a encore rien répondu dans la
classe politique certains demandent à ce
que l'exécutif organise un événement
officiel pour honorer l'un des plus
grands hommes de l'histoire française
qu'on le veuille ou non
à l'instar du député les républicains
julien aubert pour lui si l'état refuse
de commémorer napoléon cela signifie que
l'état refuse de célébrer le récit
national est ce qui fait de nous des
français la haye la ministre de
l'égalité et de la diversité elisabeth
moreno n'a pas pris position
elle rappelle quand même comme napoléon
était l'un des plus grands misogyne
un député de la france insoumise le
pardon député la france insoumise alexis
corbière a dit pour sa part que napoléon
lui est elle aux fossoyeurs de la
république alors ne faut-il pas entendre
aussi ses critiques sur napoléon
évidemment mais ceux qui soutiennent la
commémoration ou la célébration de
napoléon disent quelque chose de
légitime
attention aux anachronismes et aux
critiques faites avec le regard du 21ème
siècle ne s'agit pas de dire que
napoléon était un saint comme le
rappelle julien aubert
mais n'oublions pas qu'une partie de
l'héritage républicain
on le doit aussi à napoléon comme le
code civil la banque de france le
baccalauréat ou la présence des préfets
alors oui il napoléon a par exemple
rétabli l'esclavagé en france en 1802
n'oublions pas que malheureusement cette
époque l esclavage et est mondialisée un
défenseur de l'héritage de l'empereur
membres
de l'association france bonapartiste
tenait à nous rappeler d'ailleurs que
napoléon avait aussi aboli l esclavage à
malte où le servage dans une partie de
la pologne
quand il avait conquis ses territoires
l'histoire souvent ce n'est pas tout
noir ou tout blanc alors bastien cela
signifie t'il que la france attendant
finalement de voir que le côté sombre de
ses personnages historiques nos
différents interlocuteurs souvent des
gaullistes et certains républicains de
gauche font souvent ce constat pour ce
qui est de la repentance de l'excusé
permanente
la france est présente des minorités que
d'aucuns nomment les déconstructeurs les
des coloniaux ou les indigéniste
agissent en ce sens et parfois influence
or met en cause une statue de napoléon à
romans on veut déboulonner colbert on
vandalisent celle de victor schoelcher
aux antilles parce qu'il était pour ses
détracteurs le symbole du colon blanc
alors qu'il était l'un de ces grands
hommes qui au contraire ont permis
l'abolition de l'esclavagé en 1848 la
nation a pour héritage commun l'histoire
française et des minorités veulent
dynamité cela napoléon fait partie de
cette histoire avec ses côtés sombres
aussi nombre de républicains craignent
que la france renoue une partie de son
histoire pour faire plaisir aux
indigéniste entre autres l'un des
exemples frappants
en 2005 le président de l'époque jacques
chirac avait refusé de commémorer la
victoire napoléonienne d'austerlitz mais
la même année il envoyait notre
porte-avions pour la commémoration de la
défaite à trafalgar
n'est ce pas symbolique et oui c'est
sans doute symbolique merci beaucoup en
tout cas bastien pour toutes ces
explications
un long papier une longue explication et
le débat donc qui est ouvert à retrouver
sur rt sur le web